The real meaning of the name Antarctica kind
of blew my mind. Okay, so the first part “Ant-”
is sort of like “anti-” just means sort of
“opposite,” but “-arctica” means “bear.” Okay,
so Antarctica literally means like “opposite
of the bear.” Obviously, there's no bears in
Antarctica, by the way. And no, it has nothing
to do with polar bears being in the Arctic or
the north. It has to do with the stars. There's
this one constellation that most of us know as
the Big Dipper, but civilizations, for a lot of
years looked up at the stars and saw this as a
bear. Ursa Major. Sailors and navigators always
use this constellation to find the North Star,
Polaris. The way I always thought
about it is like the “dipper” of
the Big Dipper kind of points to Polaris.
That's north, okay? So for a lot of people,
this Big Dipper that kind of looks like a bear
up in the sky is sort of synonymous with “north.”
And so that's how we get “Antarctica.” That's
the opposite of the bear. If the bear is north,
then the opposite of the north bear is
the south. The South Pole. Antarctica.